- The song lyric is from
"Adventure Time" and BMO sings it,
and she says, "You and I
will always be back then."
And it reminds me of my aunt
who I lost a cancer two years ago.
It's from a cartoon that I grew up with,
and I just I feel so much.
And it's a stupid little
song, but I just love it.
It really spoke to me.
'Cause around the time she
died, I heard it again.
I was actually re-watching the show.
And it just reminds me of her, like,
we're always gonna be back then.
She was amazing.
She was such a presence in her life.
She made an impact on everyone.
She was an amazing person.
And my family has never
been the same without her.
And I feel her with me every day.
And that song just really,
it means a lot to me.
It does.
- There is a song off of the first
Phoebe Bridger's album
called "Would You Rather".
And I know it's a song
about her little brother,
and it always makes me
think of my little brother.
So the lyric is "We have the same face.
"I laid awake as someone
shoved you up against a wall.
"Quarantined in a bad dream.
"He's half the man and
you're twice as tall."
So.
I have like the same face
as my little brother.
He's three years younger than me,
but I've had people tell us
we look like twins before.
And he had a really rough time.
He got bullied pretty bad.
And I always felt bad that
like I wasn't able to
protect him all the time.
But we're really close now.
And yeah, that lyric always gets to me.
- It would be Frank Ocean "Lenses"
when he says, "I feel their smiles on me."
I think about that
specifically to someone,
'cause I always feel like when I'm talking
or saying something like
he's just staring at me.
And so it makes me like
really think about him.
- [Interviewer] Well wait,
when you're talking to this one person,
it feels like he's just-
- Yeah.
'Cause he'll just be like
staring at me, admiring me.
or like I could be going getting food,
and I'll turn around and I realize like
he's staring at me and I'm like, "Oh wow.
"He like really doesn't
take his eyes off me."
And like, I'll turn
around and he's smiling.
And so I'm like, "Wow.I can
really feel his smiles on me."
Like, when I'm out there doing something.
- [Interviewer] And this is
someone you are with right now?
- Yeah.
- So Phoebe Bridgers, in
her song, "I See You".
It has this lyric.
"I'm too close, I can
see the brush strokes."
And it just reminds me of
this relationship where
I'd kind of like made
up who this person was.
And when I really got to know them,
they were nothing like that.
And it just like reminds me to like
take time getting to know people,
and like not trust what's on the outside,
'cause a person can just be
so different on the inside.
- There's this song by Carole King
called "You've Got A Friend".
She's like, "You just call up my name,
"and you know wherever I am,
"I'll come running to see you again."
That's like my friend Alex to me.
One time I got stood up on a date,
and I gave her like my movie tickets
and she realized it was
because I got stood up.
So she basically was like,
"We're gonna go to this movie."
And she put on really nice dress
and like wore a bunch of
makeup and bought me dinner,
and like she took me out to that movie
that my date stood me up on.
And so she's always been
a good friend to me.
- One lyric that I was thinking of is from
mxmtoon song "Prom Dress".
And it's like, "I'm sitting
here crying in my prom dress.
"I'd be the prom queen
if crying was a contest."
And it reminds me of this experience I had
when I was a freshman in high school.
And this guy asked me to
be his homecoming date,
and the entire time I was there
he was just hanging out with another girl,
and it like made me really sad.
Like, I went home and I cried.
And he like posted that he was hanging out
with her after the dance.
And that was like a core memory.
- The lyric is "They sprinkled
moon dust in your hair,
"and golden starlight
in your eyes of blue."
And it's from the song "Close To You".
And it makes me think of my dad.
I saw this baby picture
of him when I was younger
where he had like blonde
hair and blue eyes,
and just, I knew him
as an adult obviously,
so like when he was in like his
more stressed part of his life.
But that lyric always made me imagine
what he was like as a child,
'cause his parents always say
he was like super vibrant and lively.
So I don't know, it just,
it makes me think of who
he was before I knew him,
and it makes me really happy.
- I think it's, "Oh child in this world,
"Strange how we forget the
things that made us first smile."
And it always makes me
think of my grandmother.
Because the whole song, it's
called "For Jasmine" by Boa,
and it's just about like this woman
talking about her love for her child.
And my, I was raised with my grandmother.
And then when I was 10 my grandma
got diagnosed like really severe dementia.
So then, from like when
I was like a teenager,
like a lot of my, well
I still am a teenager.
But just a lot of that kind of became
like I was caring like for her.
And I think that like switch,
I felt like it was what she was to me
and what I kind of like became for her.
And I'm sad.
- "Sleep Apnea" by the Beach Fossils.
The lyric is, "Sometimes I no longer know
"what it means to care about
the things you wanna do.
"Everybody's living or they're dead,
"and I'm still in my bed
and I don't have a clue."
- [Interviewer] What
does it remind you of?
- Myself.
I've had moments in life where
it's been so, I don't know
like how to explain that.
Everyone has low points in their life.
And sometimes it feels like,
no matter who you talk to,
maybe they don't get it.
But that song for some reason,
it just feels like it
grasps the feeling correctly
of just being so depressed
and not wanting to move,
and having no motivation.
And watching everyone around you
kind of move up in life when
you're in your twenties,
and things like that.
So I think that's why I kind of really,
that lyric touches me a lot.
- I'd have to do Kate Bush's
"Running Up That Hill".
And she says she wishes
that she could change bodies
with the other person,
and to feel their pain and
take the pain away from them.
That would probably be something
that reminds me of someone.
- [Interviewer] Who does it remind you of?
- I have a lot of transsexual friends
that I wonder what it's
like to be in their body,
and you know, to have them not
be in pain in their own body.
"And if only I could,
I'd make a deal with God,
"and I'd get him to swap our places.
"I'll be running up that road,
"I'll be running up that hill
"I'll be running up that building.
"Say if I only could."
- "I watched the moon, let it run my mood.
"Can't stop thinking of you."
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Who does it remind you of?
- This French boy that I was
in love with over the summer.
Well, I definitely feel like my soul mate
is on the other side
of the world right now.
He's, God, (chuckles)
he's like a very safe person.
And he kind of just feels like nighttime
in like a good way.
So whenever I hear that song
I think of like the feelings
that I have for him,
and how safe he makes me feel.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What's a song lyric
that reminds you of someone,
like a specific someone?
♪ Baby, I'm gonna leave you ♪
- You know that song?
♪ I'm gonna leave you in the summertime ♪
- [Interviewer] Wait, who
does it remind you of?
- I'm leaving a mad in the summertime.
- "I Want You Around" by Snow Allegra.
- [Interviewer] Who does it remind you of?
- Who?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- This person that I should not like
that is a total boy.
But I, you know what?
I do like him.
I'm guarded, so I shouldn't like him.
You know what I mean?
But anyway, that song
really hits in a way that,
hits the soul deep in here.
- I think the song "You Are My Sunshine",
which is like a really old classic song.
That reminds me of my mom.
She used to sing that a lot to
me a lot when I was younger.
And I've been thinking
about her a lot recently.
I just moved to New York like
two weeks ago for school.
It's a really simple lyric.
I used to mess it up all
the time when I was three.
I used to sing it a lot as a kid,
but it's always been
very dear to my heart.
So is my mom. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Have you told her
that it reminds you of her?
- No, I should. I should.
I should text her after this. Yeah.
- Bruce Springsteen, any song.
"Down By The River", "Born To Run",
any of his songs, a whole hunk of my life
and a whole particular person.
- [Interviewer] So who does it-
- [Daughter] Who is it?
- Oh, happens to be her father.
I can never remember lyrics,
but it always has to do with a yearning,
a love and a yearning.
And sort of doing everything against
society and culture,
and just loving the one
that you're with, literally.
Apart from the rest of the world.
- [Interviewer] So are you still with him?
- Oh, no.
No I'm not, actually, no.
It's just that one of us
wanted to have children
and one of us didn't.
And that's why I'm sitting next to his.
But not mine.
We didn't separate because
we didn't love each other anymore.
That's the difference between us
and a lot of divorces or separations.
We loved each other.
We had different things we wanted to do.
So after he went off and made babies,
we opened up a business together.
And we built restaurants.
And we built restaurants for
the last 25 years together.
We both ran the same company.
So we saw each other
and talked to each other
day and night all the time.
And then, when he had these children,
although I hate children, hate children,
I fell in love with his
children one at a time.
Unexpectedly.
Have no idea why or how.
Now they are both my Goddaughters.
You know, when you talk about
modern family on television
and everything like
that and everybody has,
you know, 2 mothers and 14 whatevers.
We have our own strangely
constructed family.
But I'm not in his life
in any competitive way.
I do not sleep with him.
I do not want him. I do
not want his daughters.
I just sort of slid in
in a way where we never knew
that there was gonna be a slot
for such a person.
And I never knew I would
wanna be in that slot.
But there is a slot,
and somehow I fit into it.
And here we are.
And I have to tell you
that it is 50 years later.
Okay. How do you like that?
Well, we didn't talk
politics, so that was good.
(laughing) Politics are like really boring
compared to what I just gave you.
- [Interviewer] Okay,
well thank you so much.
- It was a pleasure.
It really was a pleasure.
- Really appreciate it.
Hey everyone.
For those of you who are new,
my name is Thoraya and I'm
the girl behind the camera.
Make sure sure to subscribe
and hit the notification
bell so you'll be notified
every time I have a new episode up.
And follow me on Instagram,
I'll be posting more on there.
As always, thank you guys for everything.
I love you all and I'll see you next time.
(soft music)